alors les n'at-on vrai nom c'est les
namas médina non je le dis et gaston
lesnard fou voilà audi pas mahfouf on
dit merci au fait on peut dire les deux
donc tu as pris les la situation
pourquoi tu as jeudi de la situation
pour ceux qui ne savent pas pour
partager toutes les situations voilà
c'est ça a beaucoup réfléchi mais ça
marche ça m'a 22 ans donc sur les
réseaux depuis 2012 sur youtube depuis
trois ans 1,7 million d'abonnés youtube
236 millions de vues sur youtube 2,5
millions d'abonnés un stade 1,3 million
d'abonnés sur tik tok numéro un des
ventes de livres avec toujours plus qui
est la mienne en fait c'est quoi le
chiffre qui trompe plus faire là dedans
je crois que c'est laid mais vu youtube
ah ouais ouais parce que c'est les accès
les gens qui sont venus ont regardé ce
que j'ai fait ça fait que le livre
cartonné derrière un évidemment alors
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que plus de
200000 ventes énormes aux livres thé
numéro enfonce pourquoi tu as décidé de
sortir se dit c'est toi qui a eu l'idée
ou cdh a cédé dit et on met donc pas un
contenu sur les réseaux qui est quand
même très éphémère un story c'est dans
24 heures une vidéo le temps que tu en
poste une autre elle est un peu morte
quoi et je voulais un livre qui parce
que c'est un bel objet qui donne dans le
temps c'est un truc que tu es sur une
étagère et j'ai fait une étude
j'ai fait un bac l donc du coup j'avais
vraiment mal le livre ça mais le blessé
sacré dont peut-être qu'on va étudier
les la situation au bac et l'eau
maintenant c'est dire tout haut rhin où
les titres de bilal un ce serait pas mal
aussi
alors celui de pratiquer un liste pour
la bonne humeur l'esprit positif on en a
besoin en ce moment tu résume en une
formule plus égale plus un jeu
complètement d'accord avec toi lui ségal
plus il faut arrêter de se prendre la
tête
voilà plus égale plus c'est à l'époque à
baigorri et que la positivité et
aujourd'hui à l'est la situation c'est
plus que des petites piqûres de rappel
n'était pas ça va aller c'est quoi tes
trois conseils pour les téléspectateurs
pour la balade toujours toujours d'être
positive
jeff se dire qu'il ya des jours où ça va
pas il faut les accepter c'est dire que
le lendemain pour ça la chance d'avoir
des amis fait sa pub parce qu'il est là
très potes tous les deux un cd marans en
fait on a galéré ensemble c'est ça qui
est drôle vous avez pas galérer
longtemps vous avez 22 regarder montiel
s'il vous plaît ces 55 ans de galère non
mais oh on a galéré mais cela on dérape
ville aux hébreux daniel moreau cgt marc
ans c'était marrant quand même parce
qu'il y avait il y avait cette période
là où on commençait et ou l'ena et moi
on était les deux seuls à pas avoir de
sous pour faire les grandes vacances à
los angeles que tous les autres heures
influençant pouvait pas donc je squatter
chez elle et squatter chez moi et on
visite des vidéos et pendant cette
période tous les autres sites en
vacances il n'en faisait pas doxa small
à côté d'un truc
elle a filmé ma reprise de diana qu'à
moi qui a fait tout l'envers après pour
moi c'était ça cesse et acteurs venus
c'était chez elle que j'ai qu'on la
filme et à la france entre dans son sac
à dos on galérait tient les prêts
maintenant quand on voit les trucs qui
se passent quand on voit qu'on est sur
des plateaux télé ensemble qu'avec elle
à son livre que j'ai des albums qui
sortent des fois on a ces petits moments
de réalisation à 10 heures du matin sur
des messages
si on était sur le canapé on pleurait
ses ouvrages